réduit tous les trois mois
gwenaëlle bénard seront à
l'établissement français du sang au
chesnay aujourd'hui on lui prélève 450
millilitres un traitement unique et
indispensable pour sa pathologie
car le jeune homme est atteint
d'hémochromatose c'est-à-dire un excès
de fer dans le son c'est la première
maladie génétique de france gt banc un
peu plus de trois mois où je leur mets
très peu et très mal donc
à force de voir des médecins et
finalement le médecin de famille qui est
de bretagne qui a eu l'idée de faire
analyser mon père et c'est là qu'on a
découvert que j'avais un taux de fret il
très élevé pour être touchés par cette
maladie il faut avoir hérité de deux
gènes provenant l'un du père l'autre de
la mer donc si on n'a pas ces deux gènes
on n'a pas la maladie
donc finalement il ya assez peu de
chance de l'avoir mais on a suffisamment
pour que ça soit effectivement la
première maladie génétique en france
gwenaëlle a découvert sa maladie il y a
deux ans et si la pathologie n'est pas
traitée rapidement le faire peut se
déposer sur les organes tels que le foie
et générer des tumeurs
d'où la nécessité de pratiquer ce que
l'on appelle des saignées la plus grande
partie des réserves de l'organisme enfer
se trouve dans les globules rouges et
donc on conçoit bien que si on fait des
saignées donc on va retirer une partie
des globules rouges et bien l'organisme
va se defendre va réagir en synthétisant
d'autres globules rouges pour remplacer
ceux qu'on a retirés et pour fabriquer
ces nouveaux globules rouges
il va puiser en priorité dans les
organes qui sont surchargés en faire
c'est comme ça que l'on peut obtenir
petit à petit une des saturations de
l'organisme en faire donc c'est un terme
qui peut paraître un peu obsolète la
saignée mais non on n'a pas trouvé mieux
parce que ça dit bien ce que ça veut
dire
les symptômes peuvent être trompeurs
forte fatigue douleurs musculaires
troubles sexuels assigne de diabète ou
encore faible densité osseuse la maladie
chez les femmes se déclarent plutôt à la
ménopause
en france une personne sur 300 et
porteuses du gène déficient une semaine
nationale de sensibilisation se déroule
jusqu'au 1er juin
une personne qui vient